MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Dina.
What are you doing?
[ALARM RINGS]
DINA PORTMAN:
Well, the last time
we talked, we helped Katie
at CatTube use webhooks
to set up a system for
processing GitHub issues.
I'm worried the
functions may not
complete before they time out,
or there might be an error
and the whole thing will fail.
MARTIN OMANDER: I think
we have just the thing
to help Katie
improve her webhook.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINA PORTMAN: Katie's
webhook is currently
set up to create notifications,
trigger an action,
and stream data into BigQuery.
MARTIN OMANDER: That's
a lot for one webhook.
DINA PORTMAN: You're right.
Her current system
works, but it's fragile.
Everything is tangled together
and running synchronously.
This means we're not returning
a response to GitHub until all
the functions have completed.
MARTIN OMANDER:
That's risky business,
given that each
of these services
are constrained by timeouts.
Cloud Run has a
15-minute timeout,
but GitHub wants
a valid response
within 10 seconds
of its request.
Katie's request must be
completed by the shorter
of these two timeouts.
DINA PORTMAN:
Katie will probably
be able to complete all three
functions in under 10 seconds.
But I wouldn't want
to rely on "probably."
Luckily, we can use pub/sub
to asynchronously handle
the events from the GitHub API.
Katie creates a new
Cloud Run endpoint
to be the initial
webhook target.
This new endpoint will
verify the signature,
publish the message to
pub/sub, and quickly return
a 200 OK status message
to GitHub, thus allowing
the rest of the work to be
processed asynchronously.
MARTIN OMANDER:
But once you send
the message to pub/sub, how do
you trigger those functions?
DINA PORTMAN: Well, we need
to create another service
and have it subscribed
to the pub/sub topic.
This way, it'll be triggered
whenever a message is
posted to the topic.
For additional security,
when we create the service,
we should allow only
authorized requests
and set up pub/sub to send
us authorization tokens.
Here, we can look at our
reconfigured Slack function.
It's confirming that
the data it receives
looks like a pub/sub
message, and then triggers
the notification to Slack.
Thanks to our
setup, we don't have
to worry about authorization
or signature verification.
Our architecture looks a
little more complicated now,
but we've solved our
issue with the timeouts.
And as an added bonus,
this kind of decoupling
creates a system that is
better able to handle errors.
MARTIN OMANDER: What
do you mean, Dina?
DINA PORTMAN: Well, by creating
separate services for our three
different functions, we
ensure that if one service has
an error the other
two are not affected.
This is one of the benefits of
a microservice architecture.
MARTIN OMANDER: That's great.
But what do we do about the
errors in the broken service?
DINA PORTMAN: If the message
is not successfully delivered,
pub/sub will keep retrying
until it succeeds.
Once we have the
service back online,
the messages will be processed
through our healthy service.
MARTIN OMANDER: So before,
Katie's webhook target worked,
but it was
synchronously triggering
three distinct functions.
Meaning it was at
risk for timeouts,
and for one error
in one function
taking down the whole service.
DINA PORTMAN: That's right.
But now that Katie has
rewritten her webhook
to send all events
through pub/sub,
she has a more robust and
fault-tolerant webhook target
ready to take on the world.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Thanks to pub/sub
and a microservice
architecture, Katie
can rest assured that her team
isn't missing any notifications
or losing any data.
[MUSIC PLAYING]